today on the Matt Walsh show Joe Biden
finally addresses the rape allegations
against him and it goes about as well as
you expected which is not well at all
also many leftists were mad at Trump for
defunding the World Health Organization
but today I want to talk about a good
reason to defund who that has nothing to
do with the krona virus in fact the
organization has been from for many
years a leading advocate for sexualizing
and grooming children with these radical
sex ed courses and I want to talk about
that and it's it's pretty horrifying
stuff also five headlines and in today's
daily cancellation I finally canceled
feminism long overdue and it's finally
happening and I do that today alright
but starting with this we're gonna get
to the Joe Biden stuff in just a second
but I wanted to begin with this you know
there was a lot of consternation and
outrage as I said when when President
Trump suspended funding for the World
Health Organization last week an outrage
aside they clearly deserve to lose
funding just on the basis of the past
two months alone this is a health
organization a global a World Health
Organization no less that has addressed
a world pandemic by getting nearly
everything wrong every step of the way
they originally covered for China
downplayed the threat from Kovan 19 then
they reversed themselves and called for
these draconian lockdowns and and then
and then they seemingly reversed
themselves again a couple days ago they
were putting Sweden forward as a model
for battling the epidemic and Sweden has
not gone on a lockdown so they're all
over the place they have no idea what's
going on I'm not quite sure if this
performance is worth the four hundred
million dollars a year in funding that
we give them in fact I'm quite sure that
it's not but the case against who goes
well beyond its stumbling bumbling
response to the coronavirus for many
years who as I said has been an advocate
for sexualizing children grooming
children with these sex ed courses I
want to read from the Federalist they
have some details on this says on the
whose official website
International Planned Parenthood
Federation is listed as one of their
major partners Planned Parenthood is one
of the largest world abortion providers
of course additionally the names and
logos of top-tier UN agencies including
the WHO all appear on the front cover of
UNESCO's international technical
guidance on sexuality education
published in January 2018 this document
posted on the who website is laced with
references to childhood sexuality
including these statements young people
want and need sexuality and sexual
health information as early and as
comprehensively as possible children
should have agency in their own sexual
practices and relationships
comprehensive sexuality education can
quote help children form respectful and
healthy relationships with sexual
partners now it gets much worse as
summit news reports the World Health
Organization standards for sexuality
education in Europe a framework for
policy makers makers educational health
authorities and specialists that's the
name of the whole document so long name
provides a a framework for sexual
education and the guidelines for even
the youngest age groups are fairly
shocking the document provides what they
call a holistic approach that empowers
children to become quote more empowered
in order to live out their sexuality and
their partnerships in a fulfilling and
responsible manner the true horror of
this approach becomes clear when you
realize what they want children as young
as four years old to be empowered to do
exactly in educational matrix within the
document provides specific guidelines
for different age groups and so it goes
through you know children ages zero to
four children four to six six to eight
and on down the line now children from
ages zero to four we're told according
to these WHO guidelines should be quote
given information about the quote
discovery of their own body and own
genitals and quote enjoyment and
pleasure when touching one's own body
early childhood masturbation
they're also supposed to be informed of
their quote right to explore gender
identities remember we're talking about
children zero to four so we're talking
basically about toddlers children
between four and six according to the
whose guidelines are supposed to be
informed about of course also
masturbation and in general exploration
as well this is a this is a common theme
that they return to their they want
those topics especially to be talked
about quite a lot with with kids and all
age groups in pairs but there's the
added wrinkle that homosexual
relationships are supposed to be
introduced at this point from four to
six the guidelines get more graphic as
you move into the older age brackets
kids between the ages of 16 and 18 we
are told this is what this is what it
says about the kids in that age bracket
it says the sexual career of young
people usually proceeds as follows
kissing touching and caressing with
clothes on naked petting sexual
intercourse and finally oral sex and
sometimes anal sex
now the phrase sexual career of young
people coming from a giant bureaucratic
organization that alone should severely
creep you out that is that is very brave
new world right but then all of this in
fact the very idea of government schools
teaching sex ed should creep you out
it's it's this is what I think we need
to understand it is inevitable that
government sex education will take this
kind of sharp left turn into
grotesquerie of this sort that's because
every statement about sex that a person
can make is aside from the purely
scientific statements but if you're
going beyond that then all of your
statements are gonna be wrapped in the
moral and philosophical beliefs of
whoever it is that's making the
statement so it's one thing to teach
about human anatomy or the biological
facts of human reproduction that's one
thing and of course you're going to
cover that in school but once
veer into lessons on the relative merits
and proper or improper context for
specific sexual acts and behaviors you
have entered a realm that will always be
more ideological than scientific it is
the opinion of the degenerate sat who
that four-year-olds ought to be learning
about masturbating that's that's their
opinion that's not science that's not
anything that's just their opinion but
children at school don't need to be
hearing anybody's opinion about sex
especially not that opinion but that's
what sex ed always comes down to
opinions and if the curriculum is
developed and taught by hedonistic
degenerate perverts the children are
going to be taught hedonistic and did an
end degenerate and perverse opinions
there's no way around it the best way
and this is why I say you know I'm
against sex ed in general I think I
don't I don't think there should be sex
ed in school
the best way to stop these outrageously
inappropriate and not so vaguely
pedophilic sex ed courses is to stop all
sex ed courses that's what we should be
doing let the kids learn about learn
about the science of sex in science
class again that's just reproduction
Anatomy okay all the rest of it should
fall to the parents to handle and no
this is not some kind of veiled sales
pitch for abstinence education I'm not
advocating that I don't think there
should be abstinence education
abstinence education in the school
creeps me out almost as much as this
kind of stuff well actually not nearly
that as much but but it creeps me out -
I don't like that either I'll tell you
why because I don't want government
employees teaching my kids how not to
have sex any more than I want them
teaching them how to have it that's just
I don't
a government employee to be telling my
kids about abstaining from sex until
marriage the case for abstaining until
marriage is a moral case now there's
also the physical component of it where
you could talk about the STDs you can
get and everything and usually it seems
like the abstinence focused sex ed
courses tend to go that route but but
that's not the real reason it's
certainly not the primary reason in my
opinion why people should wait until
marriage to have sex it's it's not just
about STDs there's a lot more to it than
that and I don't think the classroom is
the right place for that sort of
instruction nor do I trust the average
school teacher to make the moral case
against premarital sex effectively
nothing against schoolteachers I just
I'm not gonna just because you teach
health class in the high school doesn't
mean you're equipped to effectively get
that message across I don't need you to
do that I can do that as the parent all
of this should go to the parents all the
teachers need to do is stick to the
biological basis basics
there should be no moralizing whatsoever
one way or another about sexuality with
kids in a school it is not appropriate
it's not your place yeah I don't trust
the government to do it the government
shouldn't be doing it there is no reason
why this stuff should be talked about in
school anyway yeah how about kids go to
school and they learn about you know
learn math science literature writing
how about that what we focus on that I
think of it sort of a similar to
religion the way that I think religion
should be handled in a public school now
the facts of religion should be taught
you know I think it's Christianity as it
as it lies at the foundation of Western
civilization those basic facts should be
taught in a school environment you can't
give a kid the an understanding of
Western civilization if they don't have
at least a basic understanding of
Christianity and
Bible and many of the other world
religions I think the facts of those
religions should be taught because it's
important for kids to know that but when
it comes to actually indoctrinating the
kids into a particular religious
worldview that obviously is not the
place it's not something that should
happen in a school so teach the facts of
it but don't try to actually directly in
the context of teaching try to
evangelize kids into a particular
religion that's not what government
schools should be doing
same thing with sex you could teach the
facts of it but you should be trying to
evangelize kids as a teacher into a
certain view of sex or certain moral
framework for understanding sex that's
not what the schools are for and if we
allow it then this kind of disgusting
pedophilic degeneracy is going to happen
there's no way around it all right let's
go
speaking of degeneracy let's go to Joe
Biden accused rapist Joe Biden as we
move on to news here finally answered
the rape allegations against him after
almost a month of ducking and dodging
and everything well not really I guess
he didn't he didn't really duck and
dodge for a month because the media
didn't ask him about it so there was
nothing to dodge it was pretty easy you
know it's like a game of dodgeball where
no one's throwing any balls it's kind of
kind of easy to succeed there but he
went on MSNBC this morning and I have to
say look credit yeah I give the media a
lot of grief for good reason especially
when it comes to this Joe Biden thing
but I do have to say and I don't get a
chance to say this very often I'll
probably never get a chance to say it
again so I want to say it right now
great job by MSNBC great job in this
case they grilled Biden I think that
Biden probably could have gotten a
friendlier in the interview on Fox now
he didn't know that I'm sure he didn't
walk into this he figured there's a
reason he went to MSNBC he figured I'm
lemming let me find the most far-left
news organization I could find and he
went to MSNBC now his mistake was he
probably should go on to CNN because
actually these days
I think CNN might take that crown it's a
lot of competition for it but what's
MSNBC they grilled him pretty good
it was a tough line of questioning let's
start by playing this here he is
initially denying the allegation it's
just gonna be you and me and I want to
get right to the allegation made against
you by Tara Reid so the former Senate
aide accuses you of sexual assault and
please
to our viewers please excuse the graphic
nature of this but I want to make sure
that there was no question as to what
we're talking about she says in 1993 mr.
vice president that you pinned her
against the wall and reached under her
clothing and penetrated her with your
fingers would you please go on the
record with the American people did you
sexually assault Tara Reid
no it is not true I'm saying
unequivocally it never never happened it
didn't it never happened wait so it did
happen he said it never never happened
it never never happened so it didn't not
happen so it did happen I think he just
admitted to it I don't know I'd say that
sounds like a confession to me and then
much of the interview was focused on Joe
Biden's past statements about believing
all women this is the part that really
surprised me I didn't think MSNBC would
would hammer this as much as they did
but Mika to her credit nailed him on the
double standard related to Kavanagh in
other situations and we kept going back
to this point and here he is addressing
that question you were unequivocal mr.
vice president back in 2018 during the
Kavanagh controversy and hearings and
you said that women should be believed
you said this for a woman to come
forward in the glaring lights the focus
nationally you've got to start off with
the presumption that at least the
essence of what she is talking about is
real whether or not she forgets the
facts whether or not it's been made
worse or better over time she's going to
be going on national television on
Sunday Tara Reid is coming forward in
the glaring lights
to use your words should we not start
off with the presumption that the
essence of what she's talking about is
real
she says she was sexually assaulted her
look from the very beginning I've said
believing women means taking the woman's
claims seriously when she steps forward
and and then vet it look into it
this is this that that's true in this
case as well women have a right to be
heard and the pressured rigorously
investigate claims they make I'll always
uphold that principle but in the end in
every case the truth is what matters in
this case the truth is the claims are
false believing women means taking the
woman's claims seriously no it doesn't
that is not what believing women means
actually and the distinction is really
important and obvious believing someone
is not the same thing as taking their
claims seriously taking a claim
seriously means seriously trying to find
out if it's true or not and that's what
we want the court of law to do this we
want the police to do take the claim
seriously try to figure out if they're
true believing someone means accepting
the claim as true that's belief so these
are not the same thing one precedes the
other so you take the claim seriously
you look into it if you find evidence
good evidence that maybe you proceed on
to believing the person but then we
don't need believe women either it's not
about believing women the fact that
she's a woman has nothing to do
whatsoever with believing her or not
believing her when you're trying to
decide whether or not to believe someone
their genitalia
really shouldn't enter into the equation
at all it's kind of to do with it now
unless the claim they're making is I am
a woman and then the it whether or not
they actually are a woman is going to
matter quite a lot and whether or not we
believe that claim at least as far as
I'm concerned although that's
controversial these days I suppose so
that's not at all the same thing and
Biden knows that but he's there's no way
around this it's it's very clear that
believe all woman women is nonsense
it is a it is a dangerous precedent as
Biden is now discovering because it's
being applied to him and and there's no
way around it he said believe women he
said he said assume that what that the
essence of what they're saying is real
that's what he said which is another way
of saying assume what they're saying is
true and he doesn't want us to apply
that standard to him so the real answer
here for Biden and all the other
Democrats is that they never actually
believed that we should believe all
women because even they may be liars but
they're most of them are actually not
crazy Joe Biden might be getting there
but he's not quite there yet so if you
say believe all women you're either a
lunatic or you're just lying or you're
proposing that standard as a political
ploy and as a means to slander a man
who's been accused in a given situation
so those are the two options and in this
case it's it's the latter and that's the
answer but Biden can't say the truthful
answer for Biden will be look obviously
you don't believe all women you know
obviously you got to look at evidence we
were saying that because it was we were
trying to take down Cavanaugh because
we're really worried about him getting
on the Supreme Court
we were just throwing everything we
could at him and we were trying to fire
people up and so that's what the believe
all women thing was about okay it was
all it was that would be the honest
answer and and I would almost respect it
if somebody even if it's not Biden it
was just somebody on the left would come
out and just say that I would almost
respect the honesty finally after all
this time but they're not gonna say that
so they're gonna try to find some way
they try to find some way to make
believe all women and I don't believe
this woman work together they try to
find some way to make those two things
not contradict each other but there's no
way there's just no way to do that it's
like trying to make this is a square and
this is a circle work not contradict
each other it's it just can't happen
so let's move on number two hundreds of
protesters demonstrated in the Michigan
State Capitol yesterday some of them
were carrying guns as is their right and
here are some of the sights and sounds
of that protest
[Music]
[Music]
okay so you see there some of them had
guns leftist we're very upset about this
as you can imagine nobody was hurt
despite what you've been told it is
possible to carry a gun and not kill
somebody
in fact people do it all the time in
fact the vast majority of people who are
carrying guns right now as we speak are
not killing anybody and probably have
never killed anybody okay
but I do want to address one thing one
talking point that I saw online all over
the place yesterday there was a lot of
stuff like this from this Marxist
account on Twitter says you don't even
have to imagine what would happen if
these Michigan protesters were black the
argument is that these protesters got
away with holding guns and peacefully
protesting because they're white
conservatives but if they were black or
if they were liberal they never would
have been able to do that they would
have been killed for doing it and so on
that's that's that's the line that's
what you're seeing today from the left
and that is the kind of opinion you
might have if you if you suffer from
amnesia that has caused you to forget
literally everything that happened in
our country before yesterday afternoon
because if you don't have amnesia and
you remember what has happened in this
country then you would know that in fact
protesters who are not white
conservatives have in recent history
been able to get away with quite a lot
more than this the reason why these
protesters could get away with doing
what they were doing is because of
something called the First Amendment in
the Second Amendment
that's what empowered them to protest
and carry a gun very simple but it's
been a lot more than that I mean think
about all those black lives matters
protests that turned into riots
buildings burned stores looted cops
assaulted hardly anybody arrested nobody
killed in fact the rioters were
basically allowed to riot all they
wanted give them space to destroy in the
words of the Baltimore Mayor you think
about the Dallas BLM protests where five
police officers were murdered
and then of course you think about an
Tifa shutting down streets bashing
people over the head with lead pipes
environmentalist protesters stopping
traffic during rush hour it's clear that
being anything but a white conservative
will enable you to do almost anything
you want in the name of protesting up to
and including setting buildings on fire
so that that whole talking point makes
no sense at all number three you may
remember last week I cancelled Land
O'Lakes butter because they seemingly
were trying to appease the woke crowd by
taking the Native American mascot off of
their butter packaging activists have
been claiming for a long time that it's
somehow offensive and racist to have a
Native American woman on a box of butter
never quite understood that myself but
that's what he said in fact one lawmaker
said that the Land O'Lakes
woman was sexualized and that it was a
sexual image she apparently the lawmaker
thinks of butter in a very erotic light
it would seem and make of that what you
will I mean I admit that I myself am a
huge fan and admirer of butter I'm one
of the one of butters biggest fans but
even I don't take it quite that far so
anyway now as I predicted there would be
as anyone could have predicted you don't
have to be Nostradamus there has
actually been a woek backlash against
Land O'Lakes appeasing the crowd so they
tried to appease the woke people and
they're getting a backlash for doing
that because now we're being told that
taking the Native American woman off the
box was racist having her on the box is
racist but taking her off the box is
also racist
there was an op-ed in the Washington
Post from a guy who says that his Native
American grandfather designed or in fact
I think it was redesigned the Land
O'Lakes woman back I don't know 50 years
ago or something and that the image was
meant to quote foster a sense of Indian
pride and by taking her off he says it
quote leaves behind a landscape void of
identity and history for those of us who
are American Indian it is a it is a
history that is all too familiar
now that strikes me as a bit
overdramatic a landscape devoid of
identity it's butter it's a
kids you butter its it the landscape is
a box of butter but this is what happens
when you try to appease the whoa crowd
this is what always happens it is a
classic damned if you do damned if you
don't so that's why I say don't because
if you do it and then you don't then
you're damned on both ends so it's
better to just whatever it is they're
telling you to stop doing just keep on
doing it or whatever they're telling you
to start doing don't do it just just the
point is continue along your course your
chosen course if you got the woman on
the butter box just continue along with
that because yes they're gonna complain
but first of all who cares if they whine
about it these are these are the most
impotent whiners on the planet they're
whining has no effect whatsoever and
second if you if you try if you listen
to the wines there's just gonna be more
wines that come because of that so just
ignore it and continue along number four
a Rutgers University women's studies
professor named Brittany Cooper who goes
by professor crunk on Twitter
professor crunk is her name says that
said this week that the corona virus is
the fault of Trump supporters she said
quote not only do white conservatives
not care about black life but by most by
but my most cynical negative read of the
white supremacist among them is that
they welcome this massive winnowing of
black folks in order to slow demographic
shifts and shore up political power she
added F each and every Trump supporter
you all absolutely did this you are to
blame
yes China isn't the blame it came from
one of their labs they lied about it
it's spread out of their country largely
because of their lies it's not their
fault though it's the fault of white
Trump supporters if you're a white Trump
supporter in South Carolina this is your
fault somehow you did this I don't know
how that can't be explained but you did
it all I really wanted to say though is
that while I disagree with Professor
Krunk on this issue at least I know that
anyone who went to Rutgers to learn
about women's studies from Professor
Krunk will emerge from that experience
with a usable and translatable education
that can land them any number of
prestigious job opportunities so that's
the bright side there are so many
employers out there who are looking for
Women's Studies majors I hear this all
the time I get so many emails from
employers especially these days you know
with the job market being how it is I
get all these emails from employers
saying I need a Women's Studies major to
get in here and help me run my business
but I there aren't enough of them out
there so think about what you can do
with a Women's Studies degree think
about all the things you can do you can
teach women's studies you can write
women's studies textbooks you can teach
women's studies you can do all kinds of
things you know etc etc and so forth
right
yada yada I can't even list them all so
that's that's a good good part anyway
and so you know don't don't don't take
don't be too hard on professor Krunk
she's yeah you might think she sounds
like a vile human being but she is
providing kids with eight with a very
valuable education okay we're gonna move
to our daily cancelation which I'm very
excited about but before we do I'm even
more excited to tell you about our
amazing deal which is going away on
Tuesday so you want to take advantage of
this when you become a daily wire
insider plus our all-access member you
will get two of
he left his tears Tumblr's and it will
make your life complete there will be
nothing else to do that's the one bad
thing I've heard people have said I got
both tumblers it's been my goal in life
up to this point but now I don't know
what to do you know it almost feels like
life going forward is pointless because
I have achieved the ultimate goal that I
had and so you know there's a
philosophical thing we can get into
there but we won't get into that right
now
daily wire members get many amazing
benefits including of course the the
tumblr but you also get an ad-free
website experience access to our live
broadcast the show library full three
hours of Ben Shapiro shows you get
special election insight a PEZ from Ben
Shapiro you can ask questions during the
backstage you can participate in the
all-access live shows which is our
brand-new interactive floor mat kind of
a Q&A discussion very casual a lot of
fun and the deals going away soon so
remember that's too leftist Till's tears
Tumblr's you can get when you become a
daily wire insider plus or all-access
member and get 10% off with coupon code
Walsh just head on over to daily wire
comm so I subscribe that's daily wire
calm / subscribe coupon code Walsh okay
for our daily cancellation today we are
canceling feminism it's about time we
did that there are many reasons to do
this of course starting with feminism
slaughtering 60 million babies you know
I would say that's a pretty good reason
but beyond that the real reason they're
being cancelled today is because the
feminist movement is today nothing but a
collection of whiny petty ridiculous
women searching desperately for a reason
to feel persecuted and considering that
women are so privileged in fact are
uniquely privileged in Western society
they have to get increasingly creative
in their hunt for persecution the
primary persecution that a feminist
faces is that she is not persecuted and
so she's looking desperately for
something which brings us to an article
in the stylist website called the
stylist article titled is sleep a
feminist issue this is how men steal our
sleep
damn it fellows they're on to us the jig
we have yes we've been stealing your
sleep it is how we gain our life force
it's what sustains us so you caught us
here's what the article says I don't
remember how old I was when I first
heard the phrase sleep is a feminist
issue but I know this it was before I
started sharing a bed with men on the
regular consecutive men I mean I never
felt I could cope with more than one at
a time before then I couldn't understand
how sleep could ever be a gendered issue
let alone a feminist one so she hates
having men in her bed but yet she
constantly has man in her bed
interesting interesting situation she
has here first up you go to bed you go
to sleep you wake up in the morning and
go about your day someone else goes to
bed with you you might have sex chat and
then you go to sleep and he goes to
sleep and you wake up in the morning you
might have sex chat then you go about
your day oh haha you naive well rested
single fool gather round me children in
the Woody Glen of truth and listen to my
hard-won words of wisdom as I collapse
in chronic fatigue on a bed of moss
because this is what happens when you
enter into long-term hetero bed sharing
this is in short how men steal your
sleep this is just heterosexual men of
course right she forgot to mention also
just white men she forgot to stipulate
that in fact I think it's pretty racist
that she didn't stipulate that because
all of these accusations apparently
would apply to black men too and I find
that highly racist personally and then
it goes through this whole list of bad
things that men do to keep women awake
we'll hit a couple of these she says
that's X o'clock your partner bursts
through the door shucks off his clothes
and bounds into bed he thinks he is
being profoundly thoughtful because he
hasn't broken her set fire to anything
on his way up he thinks he is slightly
creeping into his nest like a tiny field
mouse without disturbing a single ear of
corn he is wrong and then if he realizes
you are now awake he will start a
conversation on whatever subject you
were currently finding most stressful
because midnight really is absolutely
the best time for this and then and then
she mentions that he's going to try to
have sex with you and he does so in
graphic terms I won't repeat he falls
asleep within three seconds because for
him the date
care of itself and there's no reason to
think tomorrow won't you'll be disturbed
half a dozen times more by his snoring
and/or the fact that there is there
isn't a man alive who has learned how to
rotate under the duvet rather than take
it with him when he turns dog cracks and
his alarm goes off early because he miss
said it he's back to sleep immediately
you are not these points may all
resonate with you or they may not but
add up how much sleep you lose a week a
month a year to the ones that do ask
yourself how much sleep you lose to a
man's unconscious sense of entitlement a
belief so profound it seems natural to
feel his time his rest his smooth
passage through the world is more
important than yours
you can ponder this sleep an inequality
beyond the night hours then decide what
to do about it okay
I spent way too long reading that a few
things first of all I also remember that
first time that I heard the phrase sleep
is a feminist issue and it happened
right now this was the first time
because I don't run in the kind of
circles where that is a commonly used
expression because I'm not a lunatic
second I am actually guilty of some of
this stuff but that brings me to third
even if some of this stuff does
represent a common difference between
men and women that doesn't make it a
feminist issue and I'm not at all
convinced that this is a you know common
to men even if it's common to me over
sleeping my alarm coming to bed late
snoring I do all that stuff but it would
surprise me shock you to learn I have
heard tales of women who also snore
sometimes or oversleep their alarm or go
to bed late I think there are women who
do that it could be wrong but either way
this is something people do not not not
not just me not men just people it's a
people thing some of the people are men
like me but you know what get over it
you screaming Banshee just get over it
regardless not every difference between
men and women even differences that
cause inconvenience inconveniences for
one or the other are matters of
persecution and depression okay
in fact none of them are they're just
differences is all and when you put two
different people together they're going
to be there's going to be a little bit
of tension sometimes that happens you're
not persecuted you're not oppressed
you're just a person living in human
society dealing with all the things the
rest of us do forth this idea that men
fall asleep easily because we have no
stresses while women carry all the
burden and they're so stressed and
they're dealing with everything while
the man is just blissfully off in la-la
land this is exactly the kind of self
and grand izing self martyring crap that
makes it so miserable to be married to a
feminist and it's why feminist marriages
fall apart all the time because the fact
the feminist has a cartoonish view of
men and when you
you your spouse as a cartoon and
yourself as a vivid real complex human
that is not a recipe for a great
relationship and that is also why I
thank God every day that my wife is not
a feminist v if you think that snoring
is a sign of an unconscious sense of
entitlement I'd like to suggest that you
might be insane snoring isn't is not a
patriarchal plot to oppress you okay it
it is it's actually just a blocked nasal
passage it's it's not the patriarchy
it's a nasal passage that's the issue or
else maybe he drank too much whiskey
that could also make you snore so that
could also be the case but either way a
person can't really help the noises they
make when they sleep so stop body
shaming snore shaming is body shaming
sixth point is just in general people
who complain so much about being
exhausted as she's doing here I'm so
exhausted so exhausted and stressed I
don't sleep oh shut up that's that's one
of the most annoying things this is
something a lot of people do I'm not
gonna say just women do it but people
are very proud of have you noticed this
how proud people can be of their lack of
sleep their alleged lack of sleep the
stress they're under how busy they are
they love telling you about it if
somebody only got three hours of sleep
last night they're gonna tell you
they're gonna find a way to work it into
the conversation because they're so
proud of it first I don't understand I
don't know why and then the seventh
point is that feminism is humanity's
greatest mistake and that's all and
that's why feminism is canceled let's
move on to emails got a couple of
interesting emails here and you can
email the show by becoming a daily wire
member you get access to the mailbag as
well as many other perks that we just
went over this is from Kevin says hey
Matt my brother and I are big fans of
the show and I would like some advice I
have a female friend from college we
have been friends for six years the
friendship is platonic and there is no
romantic feelings between us I think I
meant platonic platonic would be like
a relationship on Pluto or a
relationship with an alien from Pluto
which would be very interesting and if
that's what this is then that really
puts a different tenor on on our
conversation about a year ago she began
dating her now her now fiance who has
expressed concern about her hanging out
with another man both her and I have
attempted to assuage sure him that there
is nothing going on when we spend time
with each other but nothing seems to
bring his mind ease I have attempted to
befriend the fiance only to learn he
makes snide remarks about my friend and
I behind my back my friend does not want
to end our friendship but I am beginning
to fear that our friendship will end her
relationship with her fiance do you
think I should end the friendship or is
the fiance being unreasonable would love
to hear your thoughts well Kevin I hate
to tell you but I think the fiancee is
being reasonable not unreasonable now
certainly once your friend is married
and she's a married woman it will not be
appropriate for her to go off and hang
out individually one on one with a male
friend it isn't appropriate now I mean
even if they were just dating I would
say it's not appropriate but as the
relationship becomes more and more
serious the your friendship I think
becomes less and less appropriate now
and you you actually didn't say that you
guys hang out one-on-one but the way you
talk about spending time together and so
on it sounds like that's what you're
saying now if if you don't if this is
just a friend of yours and you guys see
each other in groups and stuff like that
then I would say yeah the fiance is
being unreasonable
assuming either of you haven't given him
a reason to suspect that there's
something going on but so if it's a
group thing this is just someone you
knew in college and you stay in touch
with but you guys don't get together
one-on-one then I would say that changes
it but I'm going to assume based on
context you guys do hang out one-on-one
and and that I would say is definitely
not appropriate the fiance is right to
have a problem with it male-female
friendships where one or both are
romantically committed and
where the you guys are hanging out 101
that's just asking for trouble nothing
good comes with that and it will be your
friends responsibility to put her
marriage before you which means keeping
you at a relative distance and see
that's the fiancee should be more
important to her than you are
I mean considerably more important and
his feelings and his comfort level
should be way more important to her than
you
it doesn't mean you guys can never speak
again and then you can't be friends but
as I said the way you talk about it
makes it sound like it is inappropriate
and not to say that I think you're lying
about not it you know yeah I don't think
that you're trying to do anything with
her or break up the marriage or
something like that but it's still not
appropriate and it is it is a recipe for
at least an emotional affair which often
will turn physical but even if it
doesn't turn physical it's bad enough I
think a general rule of thumb here is
when you're you're married or you're
engaged if you find yourself having to
explain you know saying now from from
your friends perspective if she's
finding herself having to say to her
fiance oh there's nothing going on it's
all platonic if you find yourself having
to say that that's a really good
indication that you're that there is
something going on and that you're doing
something wrong you should just really
never be in a situation or put yourself
in a situation where you have to explain
that to your spouse now there are
spouses out there who are way too
controlling and paranoid and everything
else and way overly jealous and you know
I don't know maybe just walking down the
street saying hi Justin - a man would
set him off
would would would would set him off now
if that's the case then that's totally
different but that doesn't sound that's
the case here
and so I would say yeah I think you guys
need to respect the
fiancee's wishes for sure it's just not
any people who defend this kind of stuff
I just don't see it as worth it when
you're when you're married or getting
married it's not worth the strain on the
relationship and the the emotional risk
that's being taken it's not worth it for
this platonic friendship and the problem
is from the from the fiancees
perspective from the other guy's
perspective he he's gonna start thinking
well if this is so worth it to her if
she's worth if it's worth it to her to
have this tension with me and and and
for me to be this uncomfortable with it
and all the arguments were having you
know if all that's worth it to her to
maintain this friendship with you then
the fiancee is gonna be thinking there
is something going on here she is way
too attached to this other guy and
that's a problem for me because I'm
getting married to her and I think he's
right for thinking that way okay this is
from Amanda says Matt I don't agree with
your comments on collaboration you say
it's a mistake my boyfriend and I have
been living together for eight years and
have two kids and we're happy are we
quote making a mistake marriage isn't
for everybody
it isn't for us but we're raising our
family we're doing fine stop trying to
put everyone into your fundamentalist
box well Amanda you asked me if you're
making a mistake from my opinion I would
say yes you are since you asked oh
that's what I would say I think it's a
big mistake actually especially since
you have kids so let me ask you why
won't you get married it's you say it's
not for you
why why isn't it for you marriages is
making a lifelong commitment
it's uniting as one you're saying to the
other person we're in this for the long
haul I'm not gonna leave that's marriage
people fall short of it of course and
marriages do end but that's what
marriage is supposed to be so why don't
you want that is it because you don't
want to make that kind of commitment and
if that's the case then I would remind
you that you already made a lifelong
commitment to your boyfriend
a family with him so you've got this if
not a lifelong commitment you have a
lifelong attachment to it very
significant one through your kids right
and now your kids deserve a mom and dad
just who are married they deserve a mom
and dad who are a husband and wife and
then your kids deserve that one of the
main points of marriage is to serve as a
solid foundation for the family and
you're saying to your to your spouse I'm
not gonna leave I'm here but you're also
saying that to your kids it's really
important for your kids to hear that and
to know that they have that kind of
security and stability so I don't see
why you'd want to deprive them of that
so I you and you can't get mad at me for
passing judgment on your personal
situation you put it out there I didn't
ask you to you did you asked my opinion
I'm telling you what my opinion is I
think you guys absolutely should be
married and I think you're depriving
your kids of something that they deserve
and I think it's traumatic for kids too
when they go to school or whatever
they're with their friends I don't know
how old they are but eventually they're
gonna figure out that most of their
other friends have parents who are
husband and wife and their own parents
are not and they're gonna wonder about
that difference and it's gonna be
traumatic for them when they start to
realize that their parents have not made
this kind of commitment and so there's a
real instability there in a real
insecurity that your kids are going to
worry about so that's my view on it but
thanks for the email and hope you guys
have a great weekend we'll wrap it up
there Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 if you prefer facts over
feelings aren't offended by the brutal
truth and you can still laugh at the
insanity filling our national news cycle
well tune in to the Ben Shapiro show we
will get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there